we don't talk about brew no no no no
we don't talk about bruno
this is crazy this is a phenomenon this
this is an obsession around the world
we don't talk about bruno i know it's
just
hypothetically well please we need to
get ready for the goosemans because
encanto is officially oscar nominated
how does that feel this is crazy i i
feel so
humbled and so honored and so excited
because oh my god three nominations
three oscar nominations and then we
don't talk about bruno is first place on
billboard and it's it's insane it's
surreal but it's magical as disney so
being part of this magic is is really is
really really really huge for me i was
expecting one i have to be honest
animated feature and then the score and
then the song and then it's like oh my
god yeah
it is it is it is it is beautiful it is
amazing and i think it's a a teamwork
definitely involved that makes this
possible have you spoken with with lynn
or with any of your castmates
i just wrote lee manuel and uh of course
mauro castillo because he's my my
partner in in the song
and uh they are all like crazy i we
weren't expecting this this much it's
such an honor as colombian we have been
telling a difficult story for many years
and even in the art pieces and in in
everything and
i was part of something that
of course it was it had a huge success
as well but it was narcos and but then i
was feeling always the same story the
same story but we are so much more than
that we are gastronomy we are music we
are brave people but sensitive people
but human and uh finally we have this
chance so
i cannot wait to just be there and
celebrate because this is more than an
award uh i think this is uh
inclusion this is diversity and this is
the possibility to represent all this is
there somebody that you're most excited
to meet on oscar night javier bardem
he's awesome he's amazing he's huge i
would love to meet him and penelope as
well no no no no oh my god it's gonna be
crazy i do want to ask you because you
know i think lin manuel had a tough
decision when you know there's so much
beautiful music in kanto and you can
only submit one song for best original
song and he went with dosorogitas
[Music]
is definitely the part
where
the
all the the the
drama that is part of the
of
what we are as a colombian people
is
very very very sensitive and it's very
important to
tell about the displacement and tell
about the laws and this is the part
where we do it so
it's a very important part of the movie
and i definitely love the song as well
and selastian yatra we also colombians
love him as well so i'm happy for them
now carolina i i hope that you have been
in celebration mode for the last few
weeks because
your song we don't talk about bruno is
just shattering records across the board
[Music]
number one on the us hot 100 you're
number one on the global 200 and and so
exciting this is the first number one of
your career uh how does all of this feel
it's crazy it's absolutely unbelievable
it's surreal it's magical realism it's
happiness
in the whole meaning of the of the word
i think to be
just at the same time tagged with
duality and ed sheeran it's crazy but
it's as well i think it's the work of
more than 20 years working in my country
as an actress and singer when you're
you know at the vocal booth and you're
recording we don't talk about bruno and
you're singing no no no no i mean do you
know in your mind
this is a hit this is gonna explode or
did you just think this is a great song
and i'm happy to be singing it and did
you know what was about to happen
of course not of course not i i really
love the song from the first moment
and i really love that it's not
reggaeton
and we are always known as latinos
because of reggaeton but this is so much
more this is salsa music this is
cha-cha-cha
this is
different rhythms and then
with this mix this amazing mix that
emanuel miranda does with these hip-hop
vibes
[Music]
how has your life changed since becoming
a
topping recording artist
is your phone ringing off the hook
everything changed because
before this
they were like oh this character
and the other one and
this series or this movie but then it's
we don't talk about bruno in the middle
of the stream and they say hey
please sing a little bit of the song and
then the kids are screaming we don't
talk about no no no no this is this is
crazy this is a phenomenon this this is
an obsession around the world
are you thinking about next projects
what you want to do i have a new release
in one week that is named uh ayam bolero
and it's really like this it's it's
salsa but at the same time it's
spanglish and it's uh super super super
um enjoyable and you can dance it so i
cannot wait to to share it with you i
have to tell you i love following you on
tick tock there wasn't a cloud in the
sky
did you have any idea that we don't talk
about bruno would become one of the most
popular songs to make content for on
tick tock definitely not ah but it's so
fun this one is so fun
[Music]
i think
the song has
so much creative
behind
and tick-tock is about creativity it's
the perfect match i love to dance i'm
not a dancer but i love to dance so i
always go to a place and i have such a
a a big community of dancers that are my
friends and
i just go and say hey guys please please
teach me and please dance with me and
please let's just have fun
yeah yeah yeah i really have fun doing
pizza i'm hoping carolina that you'll
indulge me that we could end on a high
note would you sing us a little
a little bruno to take us home
we don't talk about brew no no no no
we don't talk about bruno
but it was my wedding day
we were getting ready and there wasn't a
cloud in
you're telling the story or am i
[Music]
you